hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to you
know it's often funny to see movie
studios try to ripoff popular box-office
hits to try to make a quick buck take
for example the year that gave us home
alone and Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
both of these films were gigantic
blockbusters as well as family friendly
so touchstone Studios got an idea duh
what if we took these two films that
have nothing in common
put them together I create our own
worthless piece of crap you've come up
with three ninjas a shameful attempt to
try to combine and cash in on other
people's creative abilities this film
was so blatant in what it was ripping
off obviously they were taking the
martial arts from Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and the health traps that were
taken directly from home alone now I
know what you're thinking
I'm not giving studio moguls enough
credit I mean nobody could be so
financially desperate or creatively
shallow to attend such an act I mean are
they really so stupid enough to combine
movies like Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
at home alone they don't know when they
freaking advertise it like that
take a look process Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles with home alone right on the
front cover
abandon all originality ye who enter
here I'm sure a lot of you're thinking
how bad can a film crossover between
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles at home
alone possibly be pretty bad the film is
about three boys who study ninjutsu with
the grandpa Mori which is kind of odd
seeing how he's Japanese and not one of
these other characters looks Asian so
over the summer he teaches them how to
use nunchucks or excite me stars and a
bunch of other weapons that every parent
would have a heart attack if they saw
their kids using the boys names are as
follows Michael the chubby kid Jeffrey
the forgettable middle kid and Samuel
the oh my god I swear that's a miniature
version of Jamie Lee Curtis KITT that's
cool it's interesting how chubby grandpa
is considering he's supposed to be a
ninja master
except of course whenever he's doing
flips and kicks then he miraculously
loses twenty pounds all of a sudden I
wonder why that is
do that next time by attacking in a
non-smoking section Oh grandpa is
obviously not talking good humor yet
that's very funny
at the end of the summer grandpa decides
to give them all ninja names you shall
be known as Rocky you shall be known as
Coke a little one since her energy
begins and ends with your tummy you
shall be known as
tum tum cunt ha ha ha grandpa likes to
make fun of other people's shortcomings
grandpa's a kind of a goof blown away
but when it comes to martial arts and
stuff he's pretty cool yes the line
between goofball and senile insanity is
often a thin one don't be overconfident
now the kid's father is an FBI agent
who's after the sinister crime boss
Schneider who apparently deals with
trading killer weapons designed by nerf
he also doesn't believe in hiring
bodyguards with those useless weapons
and silly guns nope
Snyder's diabolical gang is made up of
100% ninjas in the black suits and
everything well I have no idea how this
is going to connect to the story with
the three boys but let's just wait and
see their father always comes close to
catching Schneider but always manages to
just miss it
unlock the trap but I've gotta find
you liked it you like the way the copter
came up after I said the word fly I
trained them to do that you know cost me
like thousands of dollars but the
reaction of your feet totally worth it
your geek then Schneider actually draft
by Grandpa's house and asks him to train
his evil henchmen because apparently
they have some history together but
because this movie is afraid to have any
semblance of plot he sends his men to
attack grandpa and the three boys here
the boys find out another ancient secret
about martial arts
apparently all ninjas are made out of
cartoon sound effects you know on a side
note I should point out that the
philosophy of the ninja is to blend into
your environment not stick out like a
sore thumb you're only supposed to wear
those in the dark you morons shut up so
the boys actually do live a semi-normal
life or as close as possible getting the
circumstances they go to school they
have odd-looking girlfriends and they
even have bullies they have to put up
with or the closest thing this movie
considers to be bullies ya little horsie
how about to me seriously
how come movie bullies are always so
lame I mean look at these guys they look
like a mix between Fat Albert in the
little rascals in yet another pointless
seeing the boys challenge the bullies to
a basketball game in order to win back
the bike of one of their girlfriends how
many points to a game team do fine let's
watch you 9 you take first out okay did
they just a cake cake did I just jump a
dimension or something I mean when they
can't become a form of popular slang oh
god it's like the writers just didn't
care anymore so they started tossing out
random words just praying the form a
sentence cake that's like in the middle
that sentence meat just suddenly
shouting out stuffed cabbages why I
don't know because it makes about as
much sense as cake
so obviously the boys beat the bullies
and get the girlfriends bike back I
wouldn't mind this scene so much if it
wasn't for this one certain part
all right look he obviously steps on
something here but they never address
what it is what the hell did he step on
was he just gliding on his ninja
awesomeness on me it makes no sense
however so alright we see where the
Ninja Turtles references come from but
what about the home alone stuff
well Snyder decides he wants to kidnap
the three boys and hold him ransom so he
can keep their father off his case so he
hires three surfer criminals to abduct
the kids and bring them to his lair the
good news is jewelry guy just created
the babysitter with the pizza the bad
news is they're carrying guns at first
the kids want to do the smart thing and
notify the authorities we'll call the
police
host if we can take these three hours
ourselves then maybe dad will see that
our ninja trainings worth it some are
training or probable death I guess I
know with the summer training too so
oddly enough instead using their ninja
skills they devised diabolical traps to
snatch the burglars with I love how even
though they were notified of the
burglars presence just a few moments ago
that they somehow put together a plan
that actually has phases prepare for
phase one okay phase two we were in
there for like two minutes talk to you
come up with a plan that has phases to
it it's very good question no no they
would look at this one of them actually
does the whole alone phase here I mean
that's how much this movie doesn't give
a crap this really sucks
half of these traps don't even make
sense any how can slip on jellybeans for
crying out loud would you just squash
them and for that matter how come
everybody carries a gun but never uses
them does this movie exist in any realm
of reality it's sensitive after a while
Snyder's ninja show up and kidnaps the
kids properly after learning about their
kids abduction their parents realize
there's only one logical solution a
short balding senior citizen who studied
more Japanese buffets than he has
Japanese martial arts
so rather than send in a SWAT team of
qualified professionals it's grandpa
Mori who's gonna pull off the rescue and
just go with it so the kids are being
held on a cargo ship crawling with
second-rate pajama-wearing ninjas they
think up an idea to get out of their
cell by tricking the guard into thinking
the telephone is for him
this is a phone check is that you Frank
why is the telephone operator wearing a
ninja suit I mean what is the point is
the telephone operator a martial artist
it's so why isn't he out there fighting
with the rest of the ninjas what is the
purpose of hiring a martial artist to
answer the telephone it makes no sense
stop it so as you probably imagine an
entire boatload of ninjas can't seem to
defeat three little children in bad 80s
clothes why is the ninjas always scream
before they attack someone doesn't that
kind of alert them better there whoa
who's this guy kind of looks like an
Asian joker or something
holy shit this guy psychotic what the
hell is he gonna do
well thank you movie thank you for
ruining the only possibly cool character
in this entire film you've danced my
whole yet again my apologies my good man
after fighting like a zillion ninjas and
an oversized bodyguard grandpa shows up
to take on the evil Snider in a
one-on-one battle and this is the
portion I like to call spot the real
grandpa let's see her stuntman stuntman
stuntman grandpa stuff and stuff and
stuff and grandpa after a while grandpa
starts to tire and eventually starts to
get his ass kicked but just when it
looks like he's down for the count
grandpa still has one ace up his sleeve
oh my one weakness so grandpa defeat
Schneider the FBI shows up the kids are
reunited with their parents and they all
live happily ever after
what be friggin do but wait a minute my
name was kind of familiar jon turteltaub
turtle - whatever how come I know that
name holy shit this guy's actually done
a lot of movies including phenomenon
while you were sleeping Cool Runnings
and even recent blockbusters like the
national treasure movies so how the hell
they get stuck doing this piece of shit
I mean what exactly does this all need
it means get out of crap as fast as you
can the other members of this movie
didn't take that advice and where did
they go three ninjas part two three and
four one of them when international
sensation Hulk Hogan so always remember
kids quit while you're in the decision
of quitting like I should have quit
watching this movie an hour and a half
ago it's stupid uninventive it reminds
me of just why to film franchises don't
make a right besides it's obvious what
the Ninja Turtle home alone crossover
movie should have been Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles beat up Macaulay Culkin
now that would have been a Christmas
movie I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to